"One size fits all" on
different body types
"One size fits all" stores
are popping up everywhere
We decided to try on a few of their items
- I guess I know not a lot
of things are gonna fit.
Height 5'11, Size 14/16, Sheridan
- I'm not really sure
what to expect with this.
Height 5'9, Size 4/6, Lara
- Yeah, I think it's just
gonna be really silly.
Height 5'3, Size 0, Allison
- One size fits all hats
don't even fit all people
Height 5'3, Size 18, Kristin
- Everybody is so different that
you could be small up here,
big down here, I don't know.
Height 5'6, Size 6/8, Candace
Donilyn Tank
- I'm apparently going
to fit this over my head.
We got this.
There's just nothing
good about this for me.
- This isn't gonna fit everyone.
It doesn't fit me.
Honestly, this just makes
me wanna go like this.
- The fits okay, it not great, it's fine.
- My mom used to say
something that was like,
"I'm a size two sausage
in a size one casing."
and that's what I feel like right now.
- I can't pulling anything.
There's no where to escape,
this is basically a bra.
Emilia Skirt
- Let's get this.
So short.
This is one size but,
doesn't stretch too much.
- Yeah, I wouldn't wear this.
It just doesn't fit me.
I can see through it.
- This is the perfect skirt for work.
Yeah, this skirts terrible.
I don't who this would fit.
Like who? Who would this fit?
- Well, it fits.
Just kidding, it's awful.
I hate everything about it.
It's giving me the biggest
wedgie I've ever had.
Layla Hoodie
- Real talk, this fits super well.
- It is delightfully comfortable.
It fits, I think I look pretty good.
- I'm no a huge fan of
how short it is here,
just because I have a longer torso.
- It fits me pretty well,
but I feel maybe if
you're shorter or smaller,
it's just gonna kinda eat you alive.
- This is the MVP.
It's the best, everybody loves it.
Jada Dress
- I feel like one wrong move
and I could reveal myself.
The back is little bit revealing
for a workplace environment.
- It's not the worst thing in the world.
Again, it's like a little bit short on me.
- But realistically though
this is where, I mean...
This is where my chest is supposed to be.
This may not be flattering
but it should be able to get over my body.
Jersey has one job
and that's to get on everyone's body.
- I'm gonna do this.
This is just not happening.
I'm giving up with this.
- I put on this dress and I was like,
"Oh, hell yeah, like I can fit in this."
But it's kinda sad because I shouldn't...
I don't know, you know what I mean?
They're like making me feel bad
if I don't fit in something that's
obviously way too small for
90% of the human race.
How does it make you feel?
- One size doesn't fit all which
I pretty much knew going into this
but it's kind of a real
eye opener when your
trying on all these
clothes on your own body
and just kind of putting it out there.
- Clothes shopping when you're
a little bit bigger is hard.
I feel like this is just
kind of one step further
and that it makes people who are
actually, probably quite small feel
like that there are clothing options
that are shut off to them.
- It's a weird thing that we're...
As a society, we're just
so obsessed with size.
We're so obsessed with
how thin someone is,
how tall someone is.
- I never really thought about how bad it
could make me and everyone else feel.
You know, the goal is
to celebrate all sizes.
- When I didn't fit into
it, it felt like something
was wrong with my body and
I think you could definitely
hurt younger women
that grow up feeling like
they need to fit in one size.